roger mais là je vénérais chers citoyens
le 25 mars je me suis adressé à vous
pour la première fois à propos de la
menace du coronavirus trois mois se sont
passés depuis est d'habitude pendant une
période pareille c'est à dire un trait
mais on ne remarque partout c'est moi
qui passe mais là cette période a été
particulière ses jours toute cette
période ont fait que la situation a été
perçue de façon tout à fait différente
nous aurions eu des sensations tout à
fait différente
beaucoup de choses se sont passées et
nos échanges avec les autres personnes
ont changé nous avons eu des inquiétudes
et nous avons même connu la perte de
certaines personnes nous avons pensé
inquiet à ce qui allait se passer nous
avons réfléchi aux façons de nous
protéger nous et nos proches
les nos enfants nos parents mais malgré
tout cela c'était en même temps une
période d'espoir et de reconnaissance
envers les personnes que nous
connaissons que nous ne connaissons pas
et qui nous ont aidés et un moment de
fierté pour ce qu'ils ont montré le
meilleur d'eux mêmes mais il est très
important que pour nous dans notre pays
dans la société
les gens ne se sont pas égaré au
contraire comme cela s'est produit
plusieurs fois dans notre histoire les
gens ont été unis par la conscience de
la menace qui se présentait face à nous
et qu'il fallait lutter ensemble et que
nous ne pouvions remporter la victoire
qu'en travaillant ensemble et que la vie
humaine c'est essentiel nous avons agi
en nous appuyant sur ces valeurs
c'est pour cela que nous avons su
répondre à ce défi d'une complexité
exceptionnel chers amis je voudrais
encore une fois sincèrement vous
remercier tous pour votre attitude
responsable face à ce danger est dans ce
souci de protection pour cette
solidarité pour cette dignité avec
lesquelles vous citoyens de russie
vous avez franchi cette étape cette
étape difficile de l'épidémie et que
vous avez respecté toutes les
restrictions qui avaient été imposées
je remercie tous les volontaires qui
ceux qui sont venus particulièrement
nombreux qui s'occupait des personnes
âgées et de ceux qui avaient besoin
d'une assistance particulière niveau que
dès les premières informations sur
l'apparition de ce niveau virus qui
s'est répandu partout dans le monde
à toute vitesse cette épidémie qui a
brusquement rompu le rythme du temps
entre ce qu'ils avaient avant d après et
nous avons pu analyser toute cette
période avec les scientifiques nous
avons envisagé différents scénarios
puisque cette menace était réelle
nous avons regardé ce qui se passait
dans les autres pays à proximité de la
russie nous avons examiné aussi le
coutour extérieur de tous cette
situation pour prendre des mesures
sanitaires qui ont montré leurs effets
donc nous avons su riposter au premier
coup et nous avons franchi ce pic de
l'épidémie pendant un mois et demi deux
mois et en février début mars nous avons
su déjà prendre les premières mesures
pour sauver des dizaines de vies ce sont
des dizaines de milliers de vies
et nous avons compris que nous sommes
capables de résister à cette épidémie
mais que l'essentiel était de savoir
travailler en prenant de l'avant ce
calcul en calculant nos forces pour les
unir pour augmenter les possibilités les
potentialités du secteur de la santé
il est évident que le monde contemporain
et un terrier et qu'on ne peut pas être
complètement objectivement peut pas être
complètement protégé de tout jeu les
menaces et que effectivement cette
maladie a pénétré à l'intérieur de nos
frontières et à toucher chaque maison
mais les spécialistes nous ont permis de
prendre des décisions que nous avions
jamais pris c'était des mesures tout à
fait sans précédent d'abord nous avons
pris
j'avais décrété une mesure de
restriction et de période chômée d'abord
pour une semaine jusqu'au 1er avril et
puis ensuite jusqu'à la fin du mois et
ensuite nous avons pris ces mesures au
bon moment c'est à dire qu'encore une
fois nous avons gagné du tendre et nous
avons encore une fois obtenu le résultat
essentielle c'est à dire préserver des
vies humaines
nous avons compris ce que si
mikko spect toutes les règles nous
savons tous que la russie est un pays
énorme que la situation était différente
d'une région à l'autre d'un territoire à
l'autre que ce soit en terme d'ampleur
son terme de danger donc dès le début
nous avons adopté un modèle flexible sur
nous avons pris des mesures d'ordre
national mais aussi chaque entité
territoriale a pu prendre des mesures
supplémentaires en fonction de la
situation locale et cette approche s'est
avérée juste et c'est ce qui a été fait
aussi dans d'autres pays
je tiens à remercier les autorités
régionales et les autorités municipales
et tous ceux qui ont pris toutes les
mesures nécessaires ce qui ont dû être à
leur poste de travail et parce que les
gens comprenaient leurs responsabilités
donc dans un certain nombre de d'entités
fédéral la situation reste difficile
mais je tiens encore une fois a souligné
que nous avons un mécanisme de
réactivité qui a fonctionné et personne
ne sera jamais abandonnée dans cette
science toute la russie viendra à l'aide
de ceux qui en auront besoin
nous allons tous nous réunir nous avons
mobilisé toutes nos ressources
qu'il s'agisse des forces armées des
ministères des situations d'urgence des
volontaires comme ça c'était le cas au
daguestan dans la transe bas italie par
exemple nous avons montré que en
travaillant ensemble nous pouvons
surmonter les difficultés complexes qui
se posent à nous et nos ingénieurs nos
gestionnaires ont fait et continueront à
faire le maximum pour reprendre
l'activité industrielle activités
économiques
et ceci est important parce que la
russie fait partie
deux des quelques rares pays au monde
qui a été capable de mettre en place des
médicaments adaptés
donc nous avons un différents secteurs
par exemple l'énergie le transport les
services communaux tout cela ils ont su
fonctionner normalement et dans le
milieu de l'enseignement la méthode
d'enseignement à direct a été adapté et
donc les collèges les écoles les
universités ont pu poursuivre leur
activité sans interruption et je tiens à
remercier tout tout ce secteur ce qui
ont permis le maintien des examens dans
le calendrier prévu
et maintenant je m'adresse aussi au
milieu rural les écoles rurales
on a vu que les parents ont fait le
maximum pour que tout fonctionne dans le
meilleur rural et nous avons une belle
nous avons eu des beaux travaux cette
année au niveau agricole est encore une
fois chères familles je vous remercie
pour l'effort que vous avez tout fait
pour assurer le fonctionnement de nos
hôpitaux
rien que l'armée elle a déjà su mettre
en place 16 unités médicales dans des
bâtiments complètement nouveau et si on
avait environ 40 mille lits spécialisés
au début de la crise nous en avons plus
de 120000 dans l'ensemble du pays et
cette réserve nous la maintenons en état
de préparation en état d' alerte puisque
nous allons poursuivre nos travaux
malgré le fait que aujourd'hui
le nombre de nouvelles infections tend à
baisser et par exemple à moscou qui a
été le cas et est la première zone
touchée ce nombre n'a cessé de baisser
mais je tiens à souligner que cette
dynamique positive se manifeste sur le
fond de l'augmentation des tests
effectués aujourd'hui la réussite dans
les premières places au niveau mondial
pour le nombre de tests qui ont été
effectués sur les personnes et
aujourd'hui nous en sommes à plus de 16
millions il s'agit pas d'une compétition
ici s'agit d'autre chose
il s'agit simplement de l'ampleur
l'identification de la maladie au
premier stade pour casser la chaîne
d'infection et limiter la propagation et
donc protéger la vie de nos citoyens
dans l'ensemble nous avons forcé donc là
l'épidémie a reculé mais la menace
demeure encore aujourd'hui des milliers
de personnes chaque jour deviennent
malades
donc je vous prie d'être vigilant
prudents jusqu'à ce que la production de
masse de médicaments
soit lancée aujourd'hui nos spécialistes
travaillent à l'élaboration à la
conception d'un vaccin les premiers
essais ont commencé je comprends bien
que tout le monde voudrait que un tel
médicament utile vienne le plus vite
possible mais les medics les médecins
s'en tiennent aux principes de sûreté de
sécurité et cela concerne toutes les
classes d'âge de la population ne peut
pas avoir encore pour l'instant de
sécurité à 100% mais cette sécurité est
très important on ne peut résister à
cette menace que 6 ou respecte toutes
les mesures de prévention toutes les
mesures prophylactiques et si nous avons
un système de santé qui fonctionne
parfaitement
nous avons vu dans beaucoup de pays
cette surcharge des hôpitaux et qui a
été la cause de l'augmentation de la
mortalité
nous avons vu que le système de santé
russes est capable de réagir des
situations de créer d'augmenter ses
potentialités à bref à brève échéance et
nous avons là une combinaison entre
expérience et professionnalisme on nous
avons toute une profession toute une
génération de professionnels qui avait
déjà été décidé à l'époque soviétique
mais c'est aussi le travail que nous
avons mené ces dernières années avec la
mise en place de nouveaux équipements
systèmes de tomographie sur ordinateur
et c'est bien sûr la mpt la force d'âme
de notre peuple ce sont les gens ce sont
ces gens qui dévoués à leur travail ont
agi sans relâche encore une fois je
tiens à remercier l'ensemble du
personnel médical que ce soit les
médecins les infirmières les aides
soignantes
chacun vous avez fait un effort
considérable pour aider les citoyens
pour aider vos collègues et nous avons
compris que c'était une charge énorme
qui était sur vos épaules dès le début
de la pire des épidémies alors à
l'époque on la connaissait très mal où
on savait pas encore très bien comment
il fallait soigner les gens donc on
cherchait de nouvelles méthodes de
nouveaux médicaments et chaque jour
chaque heure ces gens là ont risqué leur
vie pour sauver celle des autres vous
soutenir vous apporter le nécessaire
c'est notre devoir c'est notre devoir
sacré nous allons faire tout possible
tout notre possible et cette question ne
sera pas relégué pour les médecins qui
ont lutté directement contre cette
épidémie nous avons proposé des
incitations financières et nous avons
affecté des ressources supplémentaires
nous avons aussi mis en place des
paiements directs au niveau fédéral pour
l'ensemble du personnel
des ambulances des services de secours
pour tous ceux qui travaillent
directement avec les malades du
coronavirus et nos collègues ont
travaillé ici pour mettre en place des
nouveaux systèmes de fonctionnement
ils ont fait cela de telle sorte
qu'aujourd'hui nous voyons comment ce
fonctionne ce système fonctionne
aujourd'hui et au mois de juin et il y
aura 71 1000 médecins qui vont recevoir
des aides supplémentaires sur moi si et
nous allons poursuivre les assistances
aux hôpitaux aux cliniques aux services
d'ambulance donc nous avons décidé donc
de poursuivre ses mesures d'incitation
et d'encouragement au mois de juillet et
d'août
mais ces aides financières ne sont pas
seulement exonérés d'impôts mais elles
ont été aussi renforcé et les
spécialistes bénéficieront de jours
supplémentaires de congés indépendamment
du temps qu'ils ont déjà travaillé
ce sera la même chose pour les maisons
de retraite pour le personnel des
maisons de retraite des pensionnats et
de tous les établissements qui ont
travaillé dans ce domaine pour en même
temps protéger les gens qu'il soigne
donc les paiements supplémentaires sont
versées à partir du 15 avril chevaux au
15 juin son jeu propose de les prolonger
jusqu'au 15 août
et bien entendu compte tenu
des efforts consentis y aura donc des
congés supplémentaires
je le répète pour l'ensemble dans
l'ensemble le système de santé russe a
répondu de façon appropriée à la menace
de l'épidémie
mais aujourd'hui il ya encore des
aspects qui sont encore mal connues et
on a vu que certains établissements
avaient besoin d'être supplémentaire
puisqu'il y avait aussi les personnes
qui étaient malades d'autres maladies et
tous ceux qui ont bénéficié de ces
ressources doivent être soutenus nous
avons financé la formation de médecins
et tout cela va servir au développement
ultérieur de notre secteur de santé et
favoriser encore le système d'accès aux
services médicaux m la mise en place de
nouveaux systèmes techniques et en
particulier numérique dans le domaine de
la santé et en particulier du premier
niveau de santé donc cet exemple cette
expérience difficile que nous avons
connue et l'utilisation des ressources
que nous avons fait tout cela représente
représente plus de 500 milliards de
roubles mais je tiens à m'arrêter en
particulier à ceux qui sont loin du
secteur de son terme et qui sont
sensibles à ce problème dans notre cité
c'est la question des enfants atteints
de maladies graves ou ce qu'on appelle
aussi les maladies orphelines et on gêne
c'est que un programme fédéral a été
mise en place mais les parents
souvent son objet de recourir à des
fonds caritatif ou faire eux-mêmes des
collectes d'argent et je tiens à
remercier tous ceux qui répondent à ces
appels à l'aide
ceux qui cherchent à tendre la main à
aider mais là encore il faut que l'état
mette en place un système régulier de
financement et dead puisque cette aide
financière elle doit parvenir à chacun
de ses enfants malades et donc que ce
que je souhaite proposer à cet égard
depuis l'année 2001
il ya un système d'imposition
sur les revenus personnels qui a été
simplifié nous avons appris un certain
nombre de mesures administratives
c'est à dire que tout le monde paye le
même pourcentage cela pourrait sembler
peut-être injuste nous mais il y a des
cas c'est à dire que on voit que les
collecte d'impôts ont augmenté après la
mise en place de ce système et donc
l'état a été plus en mesure de mettre en
place des mesures sociales aujourd'hui
compte tenu de la nouvelle le nouveau
niveau d'administration et des nouveaux
systèmes numériques
nous avons maintenant la possibilité
d'adopter un système d'imposition
échelonnés et qu'ils puissent être
capables de répondre aux objectifs
sociaux par conséquent je propose à
partir du 1er janvier de l'année
prochaine de changer le taux
d'imposition de la population de 13 % à
15 % pour ceux qui gagnent plus de 15
millions de roubles par an donc ce ne
sont pas tous les revenus
mais ce sont les revenus qui dépassent 5
millions mes parents et je propose
d'affecter les fonds perçus pour le soin
d'enfants atteints de maladie est grave
pour l'achat de médicaments coûteux
d'équipements et de systèmes de
réhabilitation et je le souligne tous
les programmes de destiner ses enfants
existantes doivent être maintenues mais
les fonds qui sont dédiés à cela doivent
être ajoutés à ceux qui va être perçue
de façon supplémentaire
bien entendu ici il faut exclure tout
système bureaucratique
il faut qu'il y ait un système de
communication directe avec la population
hélas un prince c'est un principe clé la
décision d'affectation de ces fonds doit
être absolument transparente avec une
confiance totale
le seul les médecins les responsables
sociaux ont le droit de deux ont le
droit de prendre des décisions sur
l'affectation de ces fonds
le système montrent la justesse de son
application de saut de sa construction
il faut mettre en place un tel mécanisme
chers amis l'épidémie a porté un coup
terrible à l'économie mondiale
sur le plan commercial sur le fond la
production sur les relations
on s'est tous portés à semur de
l'épidémie et le problème crucial dans
tous les pays c'est le problème de
l'emploi de la baisse de l'emploi du
chômage qui a augmenté partout ses
conséquences négatives se sont
manifestés aussi chez nous ont
naturellement et
en avril quand nous avons pris les
premières mesures de confinement de
période chômée
le bébé a baissé de 18%
donc on a une récession de l'économie
mondiale et toutes les conséquences sont
encore à mesurer mais on voit déjà
aujourd'hui que de nouvelles réalités se
forme dans le monde et le processus de
mondialisation d'intégration sont en
place et on voit que les pays majeurs
met en place un système de gestion à
distance électronique etc et on voit
dans cette situation il faut au
contraire s'appuyer en première chose
sur les ressources humaines de notre
propre pays et la russie doit tenir
compte de cette expérience pour dessiner
sa stratégie ce travail ceux déjà en
cours mais les objectifs que je nomme
aujourd'hui c'est pas seulement de
résoudre des des objectifs à court terme
mais c'est aussi dessiné une stratégie à
long terme et ce sont dont nous parlons
avec nos collègues et ce sont les
conditions les les conséquences que nous
avons tirées de l'analyse de cette crise
donc il faut que la population bénéficie
l'enseignement les investissements
l'epargne la démographie que tous ses
aspects ces aspects bénéficie d'un
soutien pour assurer un développement
harmonieux et positif pour l'ensemble du
pays limiter les restrictions pour les
personnes pour l'activité économique
pour favoriser la création et là il nous
faut évidemment un rôle positif et
efficace de l'état pour définir les
priorités et et créer réunir les
conditions nécessaires pour ce dev
moment et cela doit se faire en dialogue
direct avec la population et c'est ainsi
que nous avons élaboré tout notre
décision dès le début de la lutte contre
cette épidémie et pour nous c'était
notre objectif maintenir le revenu de la
population maintenir l'emploi tout cela
au sein verse au service de la personne
que chacun puisse être soutenue parce
que l'aide à chacun fait que ces led qui
va l'ensemble de l'économie et le
soutien aux entreprises sauf que nous
l'avons dit c'est que l'emploi soit
préservée que les salaires soient
préservés que nous ont proposé des
crédits spécifiques à taux zéro pour le
maintien des salaires avec des
subventions directes pour le maintien
des salaires et nous avons nous avons
augmenté l'aide de la part de l'été pour
les entreprises qui spécifiquement était
préoccupé par le maintien de l'emploi
donc nous avons nous avons cherché à
soutenir les familles les familles avec
des enfants et je rappelle que premier
prince était donc 5000 euros pour chaque
enfant en avril mai juin
chaque enfant de moins de 3 ans et
ensuite nous avons payé pour tous les
enfants de 3 à 7 ans les allées
indemnités familiale les allocations
familiales ont été versés de façon
anticipée et après pour les enfants de 3
à 15 ans ont bénéficié aussi de
d'allocations et l'économie de notre
pays n'a pas encore repris son activité
totale les difficultés n'ont pas disparu
et il me paraît donc nécessaire
encore une fois au mois de juillet de
payer encore pour la somme de 10000 rude
pour les enfants de la naissance à 16
ans ces mesures dans l'ensemble peuvent
aider toutes les familles russes ce qui
représente à peu près 28 millions
d'enfants ceux qui reçoivent le paiement
de juin vont recevoir automatiquement
celui de juillet il n'est pas nécessaire
de faire une nouvelle demande de revenir
tout un tas de papiers
tout cela va fonctionner automatiquement
pour toutes les familles qui ont des
enfants de moins de 3 ans et les
familles qui pour une raison non pas pu
faire leur demande jusqu'à présent
peuvent le faire aujourd'hui soit à
distance soit soit les dans les guichets
spécialisés et elles recevront ces
paiements directement je comprends que
pendant l'épidémie
la situation a été dur pour caen un ou
deux parents ont perdu leur salaire donc
nous avons prévu des paiements pour 3000
3 de 3000 euros pour chaque enfant dans
ces familles nous avons augmenté les
indemnités chômage et et début avril
nous avons sept cent vingt mille
personnes qui ont bénéficié de ces
oeuvres aujourd'hui nous sommes à 2 5
millions de personnes c'est à dire que
nous avons pu aider
presque tous ceux qui ont été confrontés
à ce problème d'emploi par conséquent je
souligne que toutes ces mesures de
soutien d'allocations chômage
d'allocations enfants chez les parents
qui ont perdu l'emploi se poursuivant et
en juillet et au mois d'août aussi donc
un mécanisme qui a été mis en place doit
être améliorée encore pour faciliter le
système des contrats sociaux par exemple
quand une famille par exemple père les
aides sociales dont elle a auxquelles
elle a droit et donc pendant ce
printemps nous avons mis en place des
mesures exceptionnelles sans précédent
et tout cela est très important nous
avons su le faire grâce aux réserves et
à la stabilité macroéconomique que nous
connaissions c'est à dire que notre
politique de budget nos politiques
budgétaires notre politique de crédit
ces dernières années nous a permis
d'avoir cette réserve et d'éviter de
nous retrouver face un fossé d'un seul
coup
quand on a vu
les fluctuations au niveau des marchés
mondiaux et nous comprenons bien que
tout cela se manifeste aussi sur notre
économie nationale
mais nous avons évité donc une chute
brutale et ensuite nous sommes presque
revenus aux niveaux d'avant la crise et
ça c'était importante pour préserver les
revenus des citoyens
donc ce caractère stable ce caractère
prévisionnel du niveau du rouble tout
cela c'est pas arbitraire mais c'est
parce que l'économie russe était
suffisamment stable dans ses fondements
évidemment nous avons encore d'autres
difficultés au niveau macroéconomique
nous avons ceci dit réussi à éviter une
brusque augmentation du chômage mais
malgré tout ce chômage augmentait est
donc aujourd'hui il nous faut résoudre
l'objectif principal qui est de faire en
sorte que les gens puissent revenir au
travail et donc j'ai donné des
instructions au gouvernement et aux
autorités pour que il voit avec les
banques
de sorte qu'en 2021 l'ensemble du marché
du travail soit celui d'avant la crise
et évidemment ce serait bien que ce
niveau de chômage soit encore plus bas
l'année prochaine
donc nous avons des ressources pour
remettre sur pied notre économie
nationale retrouvée le taux de
croissance et pour cela nous allons
conserver les objectifs de macro
économique nous avions fixé à long terme
c'est à dire les règles budgétaires et
les règles d'investissement
tout cela va être maintenue comprend
tout le monde comprend bien qu'il s'agit
ici de la gestion financière assurée par
l'état
tout cela important et ce sont des
conditions importantes pour assurer la
stabilité
du niveau de vie de la population y est
nous visons aussi l'abaissement des taux
des taux directeurs
donc la banque centrale ces jours
derniers a une nouvelle fois abaissé le
taux directeurs d'un pour cent jusqu'à 4
5%
mais encore une fois c'est le niveau le
plus bas dans notre histoire moderne et
donc ce sont de nouvelles possibilités
de nouvelles opportunités économiques et
d'investissement pour notre pays pour
les entrepôts les entrepreneurs ils ont
toutes eu un plus grand accès au crédit
et donc ça permet aux à la population
d'avoir vous savez que nous avons mis en
place un système de crédits
hypothécaires à des taux préfète
préférentiel à 6 5% dont plusieurs
milliers de familles en bénéficient déjà
il faut étendre ses opportunités
aujourd'hui pour l'ensemble de la
population et à cet égard je propose
d'étendre la politique de
taux favorable jusqu'à non pas 5
millions mais 6 millions de roubles et
pour les régions de moscou de saint
pétersbourg jusqu'à 12 millions ce qui
représente un montant normal pour les
logements et je pense que cela sera
demandée par la population je m'arrête
en particulier sur cette mesure en cette
mesure d' aides à l'emploi c'est c'est à
dire pour les secteurs industriels
économiques qui ont perdu donc des
crédits spécifiques pour les entreprises
pour qu'elles puissent bénéficier de ces
aides au mois de juin de juillet et
d'août pour maintenir leurs effectifs et
donc les dettes seront complètement
effacée pour ces entreprises dont qui
auront maintenu leur emploi donc 90
mille entreprises ont déjà fait des
demandes en ce sens
mais nous voyons bien que en réalité la
demande elle est bien plus élevé plus
que ce qu'on avait prévu le gouvernement
et par conséquent je demande l'extension
de l'application de ce programme et nous
allons affecter 100 milliards de roubles
supplémentaires pour soutenir les
entreprises et les salariés et ainsi
accélérer la restauration la reprise de
l'économie
oui je sais que je sais que les mesures
sanitaires que nous avons dû prendre
sont pour certaines maintenu chers amis
c'est une nécessité
objectif pour votre santé mais je
m'adresse ici aux autorités des roches
des régions je vous prie de prendre des
mesures argumenté opportune en fonction
de l'avis des spécialistes et des
experts pour que la sécurité des
citoyens soient assurés et en même temps
que cela n'ait tout faux pas
activités des entreprises c'est à dire
maintenir et l'emploi et le revenu de la
population donc ici on a eu des mesures
temporaires conduit à être prises mais
ici en une chose la plus importante
c'est tout cela nous a perdi de permis
de voir à quel point il faut supprimer
les barrières bureaucratiques dans le
pays elle continue à demeurer il y en a
qui se maintiennent depuis des dizaines
d'années par exemple vous avez vu que on
peut mettre en place des établissements
hospitaliers qui assurent un travail de
qualité rapidement et sans les obstacles
administratifs et j'ai déjà donné des
instructions au gouvernement pour qu'il
continue son activité dans le domaine de
la construction et notamment de la
construction d'hôpitaux
je sais que tout cela le pour tout cela
le gouvernement est prêt à attribuer un
tiers des demandes de chantier de leur
envoyer des z et cela doit concerner
tous les secteurs encore une fois
l'amélioration du climat des affaires la
simplification de toutes les procédures
administratives douar thwaites doit être
une des ressources essentielles de la
reprise de l'économie
fournir procurer plus de liberté
d'entreprendre et vous avez vu le nombre
de l'auto entrepreneur en six mois a été
multiplié par 2,5 en six mois pour
atteindre 700 mille entreprises d'eau
que là on a des z concrètes qui doivent
être étendus et pour les dettes de ces
entreprises
il y a encore encore une fois une aide
au niveau fiscal qui a été mis en place
encore une fois le régime
d'auto-entrepreneur est mis dans
certains dans certaines régions a fait
l'objet d' expérience particulière et on
a vu les résultats ont été positifs et
donc à partir du 1er juillet toutes ces
mesures qui se sont avérées positives
vont être mis en place pour l'ensemble
du pays
c'est à dire que les gens pourront
travailler facilement et encore une fois
j'en ai parlé avec de jeunes
entrepreneurs
il faut avoir la possibilité de
travailler comme autant outre auto
entrepreneurs non pas à partir de 17h
mai à partir de 16 ans pourquoi pas et
cela peut concerner 3 millions de nos
citoyens et ses entrepreneurs débutants
peuvent bénéficier des aides fiscales et
les niches issues d'un capital de départ
équivalant au minimum vital et justement
ça pour les jeunes pour les jeunes
dynamiques ceux qui ont envie de
travailler qui était hier encore l'école
est aujourd'hui ce sont eux qui sont la
moelle épinière de ce secteur notamment
dans le domaine des nouvelles
technologies de l'information
qu'est ce que je voudrais dire ici ces
derniers mois compte tenu des
difficultés auxquelles nous avons été
confrontés en raison de l'épidémie
nous avons pris des mesures
supplémentaires pour dead pour aider
différentes différents secteurs comme le
btp je viens d'en parler
le transport l'industrie légère
l'agriculture et donc tout cela
représente plusieurs millions d'emplois
et cela représente avec leur famille
plusieurs dizaines de millions de
personnes
et nous faisons le maximum pour que ces
gens puissent préserver leurs revenus et
récemment j'ai rencontré des
représentants de secteurs des hautes
technologies et nous avons vu que tout
laissait tous ces programmes d'état
autour de l'enseignement ont montré à
quel point les opportunités étaient
énormes ici et à quel point la russie
était prête et on s'aperçoit qu'on est
un des pays les plus dynamiques sur ce
plan là et j'ajouterais encore que ces
cinq dernières années les exportations
de notre pays ont été multipliées par
deux bien sûr il ya encore des choses à
faire mais c'est déjà quand même un
indicateur qui est intéressant et on a
ici beaucoup de solutions connexes qui
sont protégés pro proposée par par nos
ingénieurs ici dans tous les domaines de
l'activité vital et ce système
sectorielle qui fonctionne bien il faut
l'étendre sur le plan territorial comme
sur le plan multisectorielle et j'ai
ordonné au gouvernement de travailler
avec les spécialistes dans ce domaine là
et encore une fois le système des hautes
technologies qui se distingue par sa
haute mobilité donc on a ici la
nécessité pour eux de d'avoir le maximum
de simplification sur le plan juridique
sur le plan fiscal sur le plan
administratif etc et tout ça ça doit
nous placer en état de compétitivité
idéal sur le plan international et tous
les secteurs de l'économie russe doivent
être concernées et ce soutien aux
différents secteurs dont je viens de
parler
cette stratégie d'ensemble a été mise en
place elle a été élaborée et je propose
pour le secteur d'autres technologies de
mettre un programme mettre en place un
programme de haute mobilité et notamment
avec une réduction des charges sociales
pour les employeurs dans ce domaine et
je rappelle encore une fois que nous
avons baissé jusqu'à 15 % le montant des
charges sociales pour ces entreprises
parce que ce secteur peut et doit
continuer à aller de l'avant
aujourd'hui là
la contribution d'assurance pour ces
sociétés est de 14% et je propose de
l'abaisser à cette règle 10% pas de
façon temporaire mais définitif est par
ailleurs de même que dans ce secteur il
faut réduire l'impôt sur les bénéfices
les pas céder 20% actuelle à 3% ce qui
est non seulement comparable mais
meilleur que dans d'autres juridictions
similaire pour ses technologies dans
d'autres pays tels que l'inde par
exemple
donc nous aurons ici le taux
d'imposition le plus bas au monde pour
ce secteur
mais les impôts évidemment c'est
important mais c'est pas l'essentiel
et je demande au gouvernement de
poursuivre son analyse de tout le
secteur des technologies et tous les
deux tout le secteur connexe pour
améliorer notre compétitivité
encore une fois c'est important
s'assurer de la confiance des citoyens
et à cet égard nous mettons en place un
système particulier dans la situation
difficile que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui
il faut que les gens voient que on peut
travailler sans danger et de façon
dynamique ici en russie et que cela peut
être fait légalement ouvertement de
façon honnête nous avons beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs qui se développe pas
seulement dans notre pays mais aussi à
l'étranger et ils doivent avoir la
possibilité de payer leurs impôts ici en
russie facilement et donc par exemple en
russie
les détenteurs
d'actifs à l'étranger mais résidant ici
ils payent leurs impôts sous 1 selon un
système assez complexe et je propose de
le simplifier considérablement pour que
la soie par exemple comptabilisé à
partir de 5 millions d'euros par an pour
que cela encourage les secteurs clés à
travailler normalement ici en réussit
encore une fois il faut soutenir
l'activité d'investissement et la
création de nouveaux emplois et là c'est
un travail qui est fait au niveau
fédéral mais aussi au niveau local dans
les régions et à sa bande de région nous
ne comprenons se sont retrouvés dans des
situations difficiles parce que l on
perd 10 perdus des ressources et donc d
elle avait donc des difficultés à
financer les le secteur social le
secteur médical mais mais les décisions
dead fiscale et financière
au niveau fédéral ont permis de sauver
cette situation mais je demande au
gouvernement de d'augmenter encore à
hauteur de 100 milliards de dollars
en plus de ce que j'avais déjà et ainsi
compenser les dépenses des régions
qui ont rempli les mesures fédérales de
lutte contre l'épidémie et je prie le
gouvernement de suivre de façon
attentive l'affectation de ces
ressources est d'encourager
l'utilisation de ces programmes ou deux
développements et à partir de l'année
prochaine nous pourrons affecté 100
milliards de roubles supplémentaires
pour le développement des voies de
communication des routes pour que les
entreprises qui les fabrique qui les
construisent et qui les entretiennent
puisse se développer et cela c'est
important que cette structure de réseau
soit développé seul à favoriser la
diversification des
région avec en plus des budgets dédiés
mais les mécanismes supplémentaires que
nous avons proposées ont déjà commencé à
fonctionner notamment dans le secteur du
transport
nous avons décidé de par exemple de
soutenir la compagnie des chemins de fer
russes et l'entreprise ferroviaire
ah ah
investissez des fonds pour développer
son réseau et je demande au gouvernement
de développer les instruments financiers
qui puisse l'aider
donc cette question comme tant d'autres
a été déjà a été développée au co2 par
la commission de gestion économique
d'après la crise aujourd'hui nous avons
encore un certain nombre de paramètres à
préciser deux conditions avoir pour
mettre en place pour améliorer la mise
en place du système national de soutien
est aujourd'hui dans le cadre d'une 20
de nouveaux cycles budgétaires et je
demande le gouvernement de revoir le
financement des systèmes d'enseignement
et je prie le chef du gouvernement de
d'être solidaires dans cette démarche ce
qui est important aussi c'est qu'à
partie du premier le 1er juillet il y
aura donc ce référendum sur les
amendements à la constitution ou j'en ai
parlé souvent mais ces amendements
seront adoptées seulement si la cie la
population donne son assentiment et ce
qu'est ce moment-là ce nous pourrons
poursuivre le développement dynamique de
là et si les amendements sont adoptés
cela permettra deux fils et un niveau
plus élevé de responsabilité sociale de
responsabilité vis-à-vis de l'ensemble
du pays et je prie de prendre en compte
je prie le gouvernement de prendre cela
en compte dans son activité dans son
travail sheikh citoyens de russie
les mois qui viennent de passer pour
notre pays comme pour l'ensemble des
structures de l'état a été une épreuve
terrible
cela a été difficile pour nous tous mais
dès le début dès le début de cette
épidémie
nous avons fait notre choix nous avons
pris la décision ferme que ce qui était
la priorité c'était l'homme sa vie sa
santé sa prospérité que l'essentiel
c'est de protéger les gens et que le
reste viendra après dans les situations
difficiles de la l'épidémie nous avons
donné notre meilleur nous avons réfléchi
à beaucoup de choses ne nous avons été
plus vigilants les uns envers les autres
et nous avons compris à quel point la
solidarité et la confiance est
importante puisque ils nous permettent
de surmonter ensemble toute épreuve
l'épidémie n'est pas terminée
nous avons encore a écrasé 7
ce fut les eaux mais pour pouvoir
ensuite reprendre le rythme habituel
avis je sais nous avons chacun d'eux non
un nombre de difficultés à résoudre au
travail à la maison je comprends que
tout cela se fait que c'est une période
difficile mais pour revenir à nos
projets à leur réalisation
pour que la vie reprenne son cours que
nous ayons une activité en même temps
être de bonne humeur dynamique
tout cela soyons conscients que nous
allons résoudre toutes les difficultés
nous allons rattraper le temps perdu
toutes les difficultés nous allons les
surmonter nous avons montré que nous
savons le faire je vous remercie